mardi 20 mai 2008
9 heures je rentre dans mon bureau du
si gillett sic je le sais je le sens ça
fait plusieurs semaines que j'ai un
projet en tête et c'est la seule
personne à pouvoir me soutenir la seule
personne à pouvoir autoriser mon projet
j'y vais je me lance j'ai plus le choix
monsieur le directeur
l'iut d'annecy sera pas une vraie école
tant qu'elle n'aura pas son gala deux
phrases quelques dizaines de mots et
l'audace de celui qui n'a rien à perdre
revenons à mon quotidien je fais une
formation technique je suis en première
année d'un dut clean passionne mais prof
m'a prennent énormément de choses j'ai
un groupe de t&d soudée mais il me
manque quelque chose
il me manque un peu plus d'humains au
travers de ces machines revenons dans le
bureau du directeur
le directeur se tourner vers le mur des
trophées et me répond oui en effet l'iut
d'annecy n'a pas son gala il n'a pas été
organisée depuis 19 ans parce qu'il ya
personne pour l'organiser situe
l'organisent je te soutiens et je te
propose même de réunir les chefs de
département pour que tu puisses leur
présenter ton projet officiellement
ça y est j'y suis on me tend une perche
alors il avait aussi le choix de me
mettre un coup de pied au cul aime
sortir son bureau mais il est là il me
soutient à ce moment là je lui répond ok
mais pas tout seul jean-marc avec moi
mon binôme stéphane et mathieu le
président d'un autre bd eux voilà à quoi
ressemble notre équipe
c'est la première chose que j'apprends
ne pas partir seul pour réussir le
projet bien s'entourer
nous avons rendez vous avec les chefs de
département et dans la salle du conseil
nous présentons notre projet première
victoire
il est approuvé on a même le droit à une
subvention exceptionnelle et le prêt
d'un espace prestigieux l'espace
rencontres l'espace rencontres
appartient à la mairie d'annecy le vieux
et il est prêté une fois gratuitement à
éviter chaque année et c'est nous qui
allons pouvoir la voir cette année c'est
le début du rêve imaginé une soirée 800
personnes un repas digne d'un restaurant
servi à table
un concert rock une fin de soirée type
boîte de nuit
bref un gala pour terminer l'année là où
vous les étudiants ont l'habitude de
soirée en boîte de nuit
nous on vient avec quelque chose de
différent on a un premier enjeu c'est
fédérer on n'est que trois étudiants de
l'iut et il faut qu'on emmène avec mon
800 personnes
c'est notre première angoisse pour ça on
va commencer par créer une association
l'inter b2e l'intermède 2e c'est juste
une association qui fait le lien entre
l'administration les 8 bd eux et on
commence le tour de l'ensemble de nos bd
on commence à expliquer a présenté
angoisse est-ce qu'on va vendre de 800
places
il en va de l'équilibré de notre budget
sipa déquilibre pas de projets
deuxième chose que j'ai appris si tu
sais ce qu'ils te 20 arrivée tu ne te
lance jamais vous pouvez imaginer
tellement de choses avant de vous lancer
sur un projet quelle que soit la taille
du projet vous ne savez pas ce qui va
vous arriver et un petit imprévu à l'été
2008 un premier grain de sable dans le
projet la mairie d'annecy le vieux ne
veut pas nous prêter le lieu en effet la
dernière soirée qui s'organisait là bas
s'est terminée en soirées beuveries et
on a un lieu prestigieux et la mairie
les responsables du lieu ne souhaite pas
qu'il y à nouveau une soirée qui
viennent dégradé lieu alors nous nous
armons de notre plus beau sourire et
notre dossier et nous allons négocier
nous allons présenter avec les
responsables du lieu et le directeur lui
va discuter avec le maire une chose
qu'on apprend
il y a toujours toujours des imprévus au
final à la rentrée 2008 nous avons lieu
les feux sont au vert or ya encore du
boulot
c'est la rentrée on est prêts on lance
notre vente de places en octobre nous
étions angoissé et voilà qu'en quinze
jours on arrive à tout vendre ou presque
afin de respecter une pluralité des
présences on a fait des quotas dans
chaque département a droit à un quota de
places puisque a plus que 800 étudiants
à l'iut et on a un département qui
jouent pas le jeu
on a un département où notre quota se
vend pas on va en discuter que le chef
de département ont échangé avec lui
on essaie de comprendre fait il s'avère
que le b2 avait une soirée importante
organisée à dix jours d'intervalle du
gala et qui voyait d'un très mauvais
oeil
notre soirée il préférait la leur au
lieu d'une soirée qui réunit tout le
monde
en accord avec ce chef de département je
descends en bas d'un amphi avec tous les
étudiants ce département présente et
géré les provoquer sur leur propre
terrain je leur explique ce que c'est
qu'un gars là je leur explique que c'est
pas juste une soirée beuvry en boîte de
nuit mais que ça va être un gars là et
je leur dis une chose toute simple vous
avez un quota de places demain midi je
viens récupérer votre quota de places si
vous voulez prendre votre billet c'est
le moment
le lendemain je passe la moitié des
places de leurs quotas ils étaient
vendus ça a été utile j'ai choisi à ce
moment-là d'affronter le problème avant
qu'il ne devienne critique et ça s'est
bien passé
de retour à nos études on est en
deuxième année de suite et je pense que
vous même vous connaissez la charge de
travail qui a quand vous êtes à l'iut
le gala nous prend à nous trois au moins
une heure par jour
chaque jour qu'on est à l'iut il va
falloir définir une décoration choisir
un traiteur faire des sélections de
groupe
choisir un dj préparé toute la
logistique
et puis en accord avec la mairie
d'annecy le vieux
et parce qu'on souhaite pas avoir un
mort sur la conscience parce que quand
on est des humains dans la même salle
avec de l'alcool et qu'on leur laisse
reprendre la voiture rien à risque on
décide deux choses de faire des
partenariats avec des associations et
entre autres la sécurité routière pour
faire de la prévention et on affrète des
bus pour pouvoir permettre aux étudiants
et au personnel de revenir après la
soirée en sécurité chez eux
je peux vous dire que quand on a un
équilibre fragile dans un événement sur
un budget on n'a pas envie d'arrêter
plusieurs milieux d'euros de bus mais je
peux vous dire quand je me regarde dans
la glace
j'avais pas envie de me lever le
lendemain du gala en ayant à mort sur la
conscience
ça y est c'est le jour j on est prêt à
ouvrir
on s'est levé à 5 heures ce matin on a
été chercher le camion on a pris
possession du lieu n'a cueilli notre
traiteur on a été chercher les boissons
tout est au frais installer les tables
fait les répétitions il ya du monde
dehors
la pression monte un dernier grain de
sable vient enrayer la machine n'avons
pas d'agents de sécurité incendie il
n'arrive pas et dans un lieu comme
l'espace rencontre ça veut dire on
n'ouvre pas mathieu très bien organisé a
toujours son classeur épais comme ça
avec l'ensemble des dossiers et des
documents du gala en 30 secondes ou
retrouve le devis
est-ce qu'on avait vraiment fait un
devis est ce qu'on n'avait pas oublié de
le signer en fait il s'avère juste qu'on
avait changé l'horaire de début du gala
et qu' il était invité dix minutes 30
minutes plus tard et donc il n'était pas
là au moment voulu ouvrir au final je
vous rassure
ils sont arrivés on a pu ouvrir et ça
s'est bien passé
la vie comme votre vos projets est faite
d'imprévus et dans l'événementiel comme
dans votre vie la question n'est pas de
savoir si mais quand vous aurez un
problème un imprévu et à ce moment là
c'est comment vous réagirez comment vous
serez en capacité de faire en sorte de
résoudre cet imprévu et d'impacter le
moins de personnes possible bien sûr que
les agents de sécurité ne sont pas là on
peut très bien partir en mode panique et
d'y ranger tout j'ai 800 personnes
devant la porte qui ont payé leur billet
qu'attendre de cette soirée depuis six
mois ont fait monter la sauce depuis six
mois
imaginez bien que c'est pas possible
donc on trouve des solutions
il est 4 heures du matin on a fermé les
portes
tout le monde est rentré chez eux tout
le monde sauf no 10
on est des on va ranger on est là pour
que ça se passe bien et on va terminer à
6 heures du matin 48 heures sans dormir
faire en sorte que ça se passe bien je
peux vous dire qu on est crevé on est
content de rentrer chez nous on est
content de dormir le week-end qui arrive
est passé au moment du bilan la vie
comme les projets ils sont comme cette
route sinueuse
vous ne savez pas ce qui arrive après le
prochain virage moi j'ai compris qu'elle
était toujours continue cette route et
qu'elle avance
je vous présente ici donc stéphane et
mathieu avec qui j'ai organisé le gala
2ème ligue j'ai gagné pour la vie cette
photo a été prise l'année suivante au
gala en 2010 et pour moi ça a été
essentiel de le faire avec eux et
aujourd'hui reste encore d'être des
proches
notre plus grande fierté c'est
qu'aujourd'hui
onze ans après
ce gars là existe encore il a été repris
chaque année par une nouvelle équipe
d'étudiants
ce que j'ai appris personnellement en
disant c'est à entreprendre ce premier
projet m'a prouvé que tout était
possible à partir du moment où on a un
objectif une vision et qu'on travaille
pour l'atteindre en disant j'ai monté
cinq entreprises jusqu'à 17 salariés
organisé des centaines d'événements dont
certains ont plus de 2000 participants
comme la semaine dernière où j'étais
régisseur d'un salon à lyon à prendre
entreprendre pour entreprendre sa vie
est comme spaceman je conduis ma vie
avec sérénité
le gala m'a appris une chose tout est
possible donnez vous une vision un
objectif oui vous allez chuté oui le
chemin sera difficile
oui vous allez doute et je le fais tous
les jours mais en haut du chemin
la vue est toujours magnifique nous
avons l'habitude de terminer des
présentations en disant merci
aujourd'hui je vais contrevenir à la
règle je vais vous dire s'il vous plaît
je vais vous demander une faveur
posez vous la question de quels sont vos
objectifs dans la vie et de quels moyens
vous mettez pour les attendre
[Applaudissements]